Freunde herzlich willkommen aus
Kalifornien wir befinden uns gerade
irgendwo auf dem Weg von Los Angeles
nach Las Vegas denn wir werden in den
nächsten 10 Stunden von La nach Las
Vegas fahren und von Las Vegas wieder
nach LA das heißt wir haben viel Zeit
zum Essen und falls ihr euch fragt warum
wir das ganze machen wir hab ein
Reisepass in Las Vegas liegen lassen
deshalb lasst das mal unsere Sorge sein
ihr freut euch hoffentlich genauso sehr
wie ich jetzt 10 Stunden lang alles zu
essen worauf wir Lust haben alle paar
100undt Meter ist ein geiler Fastfood
Spot unsere erste Bestellung haben wir
auch schon wir setzen uns jetzt rein ins
Auto und werden es für die nächsten 10
Stunden nicht mehr verlassen los geht's
junge Junge oh shit das kann ja was
werden das ist wirklich eine der Sachen
auf die ich mich immer mit am meisten
freue einfach dieses stumpfe Fastfood
und wirklich das Setting ne könnte nicht
perfekter da sein wir sind irgendwo
schon in ein kleinen Dorf hier so
zwischen wie gesagt la und Las Vegas es
ist einfach geil und hier ist unsere
erste Bestellung Leute kannst ja schon
mal sagen was wir bestellt haben wenn du
es noch weißt genau wir haben ein Bacon
Quarter Pounder und ein spicy MC
crispy und ihr denkt jetzt hier chick
McChicken nein das ist was komplett
anderes es ist was anderes es ist
wirklich was grundlegend anderes forder
Pounder ist glaube ich so ein bisschen
so wie der Hamburger Royal TS in
Deutschland ne angelehnt ja würde ich
auch sagen mach mal auf das Ding ist auf
jeden Fall glaube ich bei Mac ist mit
Abstand das Produkt wo du am meisten
Petty hast bei uns in Deutschland hast
ja gerade beim Big Mac und so wirklich
verschwinden klein
aber der Quarter Pounder hat halt ein
quarter Pound Gewicht insgesamt und ich
denke mal in der Ausführung mit Bacon
besonders
geil sieht wirklich also so wie der
gerade aussieht in diesem Sonnenlicht ne
sehen die Burger in der Werbung aus das
stimmt rein in die
hlebirne ich GLB das ist der beste
McDonald Burger den hatte
[Musik]
echt der Saft kommt wirklich aus diesem
Fleisch
raus der ist ja richtig richtig geil der
Bacon ist wirklich knusprig h ist doch
Meckel Alter der würde jetzt gerade no
joke a von ze von mir bekommen von mir
wird auch eine AHB bekommen vielleicht
sogar neun mein Drink ist leider leer
bleibt jetzt erstmal beim Wasser man
sollte auch viel Wasser trinken du hast
absolut Recht ich meine gerade bei so
einem Projekt wie wir es jetzt Vorhaben
ne wo man hier durch dieses wunderschöne
amerikanische Setting fährt Burger
reinstopft soll man dann vielleicht
nicht auch noch die Cola trinken wobei
du kannst ja den Cola Geschmack haben
ist ja gar kein Problem also ohne
Kalorien Wasser trinken und Cola
Geschmack haben das geht nur mit airup
meine airup steel bottle begleitet mich
sogar in Amerika h habe ich einfach nur
Wasser und habe natürlich oben meinen
duftpot jetzt gerade habe ich kassist
drauf zieh meinen Pot
hoch trinke Wasser aber schmecke alles
andere das coole ist dass Erb seit
kurzem auch in Amerika erhältlich ist
ich glaube im August haben die hier
gestartet und eigentlich voll verrückt
weil nicht nur ich bin als deutscher in
Amerika sondern auch er ab die Story ist
ja echt verrückt wenn man die zurück
verfolgt und keine Ahnung die haben hier
Mitarbeiter sitzen es ist sehr passend
auf jeden Fall dass Sie
freundlicherweise abermals dieses Video
hier unterstützen Air ist für mich schon
seit langem ein unverzichtbarer
Begleiter egal ob ich auf Reisen bin so
wie jetzt gerade zu Hause im
Fitnessstudio beim Sport meine
airflasche habe ich immer dabei wenn ihr
das ganze mal austesten wollt er hat
aktuell wirklich ein paar nice Bande
dieals zum Black Friday scannt euch den
QRCode den ihr irgendwo hier
eingeblendet seht guckt in der
Beschreibung vorbei und testet es
einfach mal aus ohne Witz bei uns im
Büro wir sitzen alle mit einer
airflasche rum und nuckeln da die ganze
Zeit dran rum weil es mach einfach Spaß
du hast einfach nebenbei bisschen fun
trinkst was ist ein Traum jetzt habe ich
mal wieder Lust mir ordentlich was
reinzugönnen ich sage euch so viel
dieser Mac spicy der ist anders auch
hier wieder wirklich in diesem in diesem
Licht ne dieses Ban diese Gewürzgurken
die so geriffelig geschnitten sind die
sind auch überall hier in Amerika und
die sind einfach geil rein da
boah saftiges chicken chicken gut aber
die Soße ist next level
echt chicken auf jeden Fall deutlich
anders als bei so einem echten Dady P
chicken jo Ja ja ist kein Vergleich zu
so ein des hot chicken oder so ich würde
sagen guter Einstieg 100% also der
Quarter Pounder hat mich von den Socken
gehauen er kriegt eine 87 von mir der MC
crispy das ist eine klassische 7 auf zum
nächsten Fastfood Freunde dieser
Roadtrip ist wirklich nur krank was hier
visuell mit einem passiert ist wirklich
nicht von dieser
Welt das ist nur hier was auch
wunderschön ist ist dass der zweite Spot
auf uns wartet die Sonne geht schon
langsam unter bzw ist schon
untergegangen blue
au das war ein illegaler U-Turn meine
Freunde Bo das del Taco wingstop
wingstop TAC W ist ja
wir fahren fahren wir zuer komm wir
fahren zuerst
tacobär Doritos Locos Taco Supreme and
two crunchy Tacos Zeit für Taco Bell oh
shit dorito Locos Tacos der sieht so
künstlich aus unglaublich das war ja
meine allererste Begegnung mit Mexican
food ne ja das war auf jeden Fall die
amerikanische Version von TOS aber wir
probieren das kann man auch nicht beim
fahen Essen geht wirklich nicht also ist
nicht der salatp der schmechtt übelst so
künstlich normalen schnell probieren
bisschen beef Salat ungeschmolzener Käse
also Vergleich der dorito schon auch
stärker dorito schon stärker war aber
auch doppelt so teuer echt beides dorito
6 von der F von oder schauen wir mal was
Wendy so zu bieten hat hello one Bac
baconat ALR Leute Licht aufgebaut und in
meiner Hand halte ich den Bacon ner was
für ein Name für einen Burger oh das
sieht geil aus oder so diese
Präsentation in Alufolie kennen wir bei
uns ja vor allem von five guys oh ja das
ist Wendy Bro was denn Viereck die
viereckigen Patties oh shit der Wendy
baconator wir haben zwei quadratische
Patties drauf dazu crispy Bacon ich sehe
Ketchup ich sehe Käse ich sehe Mayo
eigentlich eine geile Kombination stelle
ich mir ziemlich pervers vor ich bin
gespannt wie diese quadratischen fetties
schmecken let's try the
bacon die Fleischqualität und vor allen
dieser beefy flavor ist hier viel
weniger obwoh wir double Petty haben und
Bacon und Bacon ja es ist ein geiler
Burger ne ich finde das auch so geil
dass das deren most sou Burger ist
baconater einfach so zwei PY zweimal
Bacon und bei uns niemals so gut laufen
das ist schon pervers Alter was geben
wir jetzt diesen baconator ist ein
geiles Ding eine geile Kreation aber Mac
hat heute echt gut vorgelegt ich find
schmeckt schon sehr nach Industrie
deswegen würde ich 7 von ze nur sagen
trotzem mehr Flav als die Tacos ja 7 von
für den baconator von wys aber auf jeden
Fall eine gute Geschichte das Ding mal
probiert zu haben schau mal was die
Fahrt noch so bringt ne Freunde ich weiß
das juckt euch wahrscheinlich überhaupt
nicht aber unsere side Quest war
erfolgreich wir haben die Reise Pass
wieder und ich bin gerade so fucking
glücklich diger wir haben 20:14 Uhr
fahren noch mal vier Stunden nach Hause
werden auch sicherlich noch mal Hunger
haben aber es ist nicht zu fassen wie so
sich dieser Moment gerade angefühlt wir
haben seit zwei Tagen verzweifelt
telefoniert alles versucht diese Tasche
zu bekommen keine Chance komm hier hin
belabern die die sagen das Auto ist weg
die sagen das Auto ist weg dann kommt
die Managerin und sagt das Auto ist da
das Auto ist da da dann sagt die okay
ich gehe jetzt suchen suchen und
plötzlich kommt sie bringt die Tasche
Alter jetzt kann unser Urlaub weiter
gehen
unglaublich unsere nächste Adresse an
der wir gerade vorbeifahren
Racing chicken
Fingers MST überlegen ich will gar nicht
so lang auf dies Problem eingehen aber
ep und diese Tasche nicht zurückbekommen
hätten wir unseren Urlaub beenden müssen
wahrscheinlich hätten nicht nach Mexiko
gehen können es ist unglaublich dass
jetzt einfach vor Alling weil in Mexiko
ist ja schon alles gebucht so da gibt's
keine Reise keine Reiserücktritt ke
nich okay Freunde kommen wir zum Racing
Kanes Unboxing hier drin dürfte sich
unser Texas Toast befinden einfach eine
einzelne Scheibe und das ist einfach was
Besonderes hat oben bisschen Sesam wie
so so ein Bann sieht aus wie ein Ban ja
genau aber es ist einfach in Butter
gebraten und es duftet schon so ganz
besonders ja was haben wir noch hier
drin ist unsere Kanes Box chicken
Fingers ich hoffe die Soßen sind drin
sonst raste ich da gleich aus und guck
mal rein oh noch mal ein Toast oh ja
noch ein Texas Toast chicken Fingers und
das hier ist was wirklich besonders ist
die Kane Soße ohne Witz es gibt Leute
die bestellen sich hier bei raising
Canes eine ganze Flasche oder besser
gesagt so ein ganzen Becher voll mit der
Canes Soße und nachdem wir sie einmal
gegessen haben haben wir direkt
verstanden warum oh yeah Eric sollen wir
rein lass uns rein diese wunderschönen
tenders hier guckt euch diese tender an
goldenbraun rein in die
Sauce boah
brud diese Soße salzig süß sauer
bisschen so wie eine cocktailsoße so
leichte säurenoten und ein Hauch von
Schärfe das ist wirklich ungl ich
verstehe 100% den Hype um diese um diese
raising Canes Hot Sauce sehr sehr
aromatisch sehr aromatisch dazu dieses
chicken was zerfällt was saftig ist aber
nicht so zu fettig kein chicken Thai in
letzter Zeit bin ich weniger auf und
mehr
auf und SAS das ist einfach geil auch
mehr auf fil dieser Tex ist Toast
einfach eine Scheibe Toast unfassbar
fluffig das muss man auch in die
Soß die ppen
und das Brot ist so süß Alter das macht
irgendwie so geil es ist süß es ist
fertig das ist quasi so ein süßes
Brioche in Butter
ausgebacken
unreer so ein chicken gibt es einfach
nicht in Deutschland wenn ihr einen Spot
kennt der ähnliches chicken macht wie
sowas hier schreibt mal in die
Kommentare da müssen wir dainfahren
Freunde hier hinter uns befindet sich
ein Laden der die Herzen vieler Amerika
Liebhaber höher schlägen lässt das ist
quasi Pflichtprogramm wer in Kalifornien
ist muss einmal dort eine Story gemacht
haben wir fahren zu in and out Burgers
eigentlich bin ich kein Freund vom in
and out Hype eine Sache hat mich massiv
enttäuscht dort und das waren die Pommes
und die Burger ja don't know habe ich
jetzt auch nicht so legendär in
Erinnerung aber gucken wir mal
vielleicht tue ich der Sache Unrecht ich
muss so pissen kennst du das wenn man so
vor Ziel kurz Ziel muss jetzt pissen
neinin bestell bestell sch
[Gelächter]
me Bacon
Cheeseburger no
Bacon double
double
okay
anle double double anim schauen mal was
wir bekommen you bye bye Bo sieht schon
krass aus oder es sieht ge ich find die
Pommes sehen vor allem besser aus warte
mal
warte das muss ich jetzt testen schmeckt
sie immer noch wie
Pappe ja ja wirklich was machen die mit
ihren Pommes dass die so scheiße sindön
aber so das ist halt state of the art
das sieht wunderschön aus ne das sieht
aus wie in der Werbung ja da versprechen
sie nicht einem zu viel pomes kann ich
straight sagen dre von ze ich finde auch
es sind wirklich mit die schlechtesten
Pommes die ich kenne der wahre Star ist
natürlich hier der Double double wir
haben auf jeden Fall ordentlich cheese
hier der sieht schon echt geil aus im
Anschnitt ich probiere einfach mal
vielleicht überzeugt
er ist kein schlechter Burger aber auch
nicht den halbwert finde ich auch jetzt
wo man die noch mal ist der ist schon
geil der schmeckt saftig der schmeckt
schmeckt gut das ist viel besser als
letztes Mal auf jeden Fall der ist s
geil als wies aber C war
inhalb von ze fast ne von ze
8,6 der ist
letzten Biss der ist eine a aber Pommes
3 ja Pomm ist scheiße pomes voll die
drei wir sehen uns gleich wir haben
extra in 24 Stunden geöffneten crispy
cream rausgesucht weil wir noch was
Süßes zum Abschluss haben wollten aber
vielleicht soll das einfach nicht sein